I'd be crazy not to begin by thanking
these two handsome men Liam and Clint
for such a lovely introduction thank you
both of you and of course thank you to
the Academy for this recognition I'm so
honoured I wouldn't be here tonight if
it wasn't also for a few other gentlemen
who I was lucky to work with along the
way Charles Laughton who signed me to my
first movie contract and is totally
responsible for my career
the Duke John Wayne John Wayne signed me
to my first movie contract and is
responsible for my career yeah oh oh I
have to read I read that and skal him an
old devil just read here just read right
here to search it and it says and of
course that old devil himself the great
John Ford
happy
I thought we finally got an Oscar I'd
also like to say thank you to all my
fans who have been so kind to me over
the years and truly made this night
possible I'm so proud to receive this
award because it comes from my peers who
represents every element of the motion
picture business business believe me the
admiration is mutual
I am honored beyond words thank you with
all my heart and I leave you with this
old Irish saying may the road rise to
meet you
the wind be always at your back and may
the Sun Shine warm upon your face good
night